I put out the call you guys responded so
it is time for the results for the
opening credits contest so um a couple
things before I start showing you these
this particular video I'm actually gonna
show you all the entries that I got um
which I think was eight was eight or
nine I did get a B however many it is so
I'm gonna show all of them here now
there's a couple things that I want to
clarify that I hadn't made as clear as I
could have when I initially announced
this contest
there is actually a prize beyond simply
having your piece featured at the start
and getting credit for it there was more
than that I didn't want to put that up
front because for me my hope for this
was for it to be more of a community
building exercise I guess this is kind
of a half-baked idea if I'm gonna be
completely honest I fly by the seat of
my pants a lot of the time but so what
the prizes are is there is a small cash
prize which I am arranging for payment
with the people whose work is getting
second it is people plural because like
I said I was accept accepting entries
for any of the different sub sort of
things specific things that I do so the
result is that is that there are three
entries which you will see as part of
the intro and opening for future videos
not every future video cuz because a big
part of what I do is try and get stuff
that isn't topical shot in advance
there's gonna be a number of videos that
you'll see over the next ya month or so
that are going to have the old credit
stuff in it because I've already edited
them and it's it's an annoying thing for
me to go back to fixes just because of a
way that I do it it's not impossible but
it's a big pain in my butt so those are
gonna stay as they are but aside from
those future videos you will start
seeing
some of these credits that you're having
it now this specific video I want to be
clear about this he's not going to be
monetized so that I am NOT making income
off of the entries from people whose
whose entries were not selected for
future use and didn't get you know the
the prize awarded with that which I
didn't even finish for that yeah uh-hum
it there is a small cash price as I said
additionally I am sending the winners a
merch bundle which is the I mean it's
just yeah you know it's this stuff it's
the logo stuff they're getting a
keychain a magnet a buttons and I'm
assigned business card which our rewards
also available on the patreon so it's a
it's equivalent to one of the higher
tiers of patreon sport hey I got the
plug in early this time yeah that's nice
I'll probably still do it again at the
end Oh that'll be painful so without
further ado we're gonna start getting
into these I'm gonna save the ones that
are actually gonna be put to use until a
little bit later so let's start just
going through some of these so I'm going
to stop talking and just show these to
you along with the names that the people
involved who submitted them has to be
credited under so take a look at some of
the things I got
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so there were those and this was a tough
call so I mean some of those I really
really like but I did kind of make the
call to myself that I was gonna you know
narrow it down to to some specific ones
that are specifically tied to certain
just things before I get into the ones
you will see in future videos but two
special things which I hadn't
anticipated getting but I want to bring
attention to the first is something that
I didn't expect at all which is a piece
of fan art which I'm gonna put up now by
an artist named Prague this Prague with
two g's and that's just that's just fun
and cool oh I do enjoy that I like that
it's the the glasses I've been wearing
lately that's a nice touch so that I
really enjoyed next is actually a piece
of music which I'll probably start
playing underneath as I'm talking I'll
go quiet for a little bit of it but this
is from Meg kosabu who composed this and
encouraged that it be used in any spooky
or you know creepy sort of videos I
might do in the future with October
coming up I think I might have occasion
to use this and yes Meg I will get in
touch with you and and arrange for some
sort of cries for you as well but let's
get to the ones that are going to be
used in future credit videos this first
one was one that I didn't really expect
to get which somebody submitted this one
specifically to be used for nitpick
rants which was exciting to get and it
made me laugh out loud and this is from
the Pomeranian prints
why they do like that next up our
credits that are going to be start being
used in front of Doctor Who related
videos and this comes from Dalek Chris
[Applause]
oh that one's fun I like that one and
finally we're gonna end with the one
that will be of becoming the new
standard opening intro for just the
standard episodes that aren't Doctor Who
or nitpick grants which are gonna have
their own special ones so this one comes
from cam-cam films
three-two-one studios and this yeah this
would this was a this was a cool thing
to receive and take a look so there it
is folks those are the credits that you
can look forward to seeing again in the
future that does mean the one that
you've been seeing up to this point
barring a few later episodes coming out
in the next month or so the titles from
mr. mash up that I have been using are
getting retired I I loved receiving
those and I really think that having
those improves the look of the show
quite a bit and it but it's it's
exciting to sort of have a new phase and
almost feel like it's assuring in a new
era in a way I don't know maybe that's a
little too grand maybe I'm too high on
myself at this point but congratulations
to those whose works were selected thank
you to everybody who submitted I really
did
dread that I was gonna get literally
nothing yeah you know but you know you
guys you guys came through and every
entry I was happy to get and happy to
watch and I enjoyed quite a bit so
thanks so much to everybody so thanks
for participating and whatever your
thoughts are on things I guess on any of
these credits that that you saw drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's a whole bunch of
stuff to do there's links in there's
buttons
come out if you feel like it and
remember folks you are the council and I
just run the meetings so until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]